okay let's get started
welcome everybody to day three of the
learning and testing and high dimensions
workshop
today we have uh i'm super excited about
today's program
it revolves all around the theory of
deep learning
and we're fortunate to have
chile to from ut austin
to uh start us off today chi do you want
to share your slides
uh yes so take it away thank you
okay uh thank you adam so
uh today i'm very happy to talk about my
recent work on
sgd learns one layer network with w
gains
and this is joint work with my wonderful
collaborators
jason lee alex the marquis and koski
acosta's that skylarkis
so we all know that uh generative
adversarial networks are very
widely used and popular for learning
real-world distributions
when for instance it creates such very
photorealistic images
uh and among different types of guns w
again
or wilson stem again is proposed to
improve the training dynamics again
things with
its formulation like this uh it
can actually minimize the ones instead
one distance between the
real distribution and the the
distribution we
are generating so as normal again
it is a two-player game where the new
player minimize over the generator
function
and the max player chooses among all the
one lectures discriminators
so that it can be distinguished between
the real
images and the generated images
and from this formulation we can see
that in order
to match the real distribution and our
generative distribution
that will against actually require to
solve this min max optimization
to its global optimality
however we all know that this kind of
problem is quite challenging because
it's
usually it's non-convex non-concave
however in practice uh some simple
heuristics like
stochastic gradient descent ascent
purely performs well in practice
so this there are naturally arises
question that
against able to learn high dimensional
distributions in polynomial time and
polynomial sample capacity with simple
heuristics
like stochastic gda
and in this work we are trying to answer
these questions
with a very simple setting uh as a
starting point
but first let me review some
the prior work is usually look at the
optimization
and the statistical side of gains
separately so on the optimization side
people have proved that under some
settings it can
show local convergence and uh
for general min max optimizations
there are also some studies uh mostly
uh for global convergence they can only
show for
non-convex concave or convex concave
setting
and there is also some local
algorithms that achieve local
optimization for non-convex non-concave
objectives
and on the statistical side there are
proposals to kill the mode of collapse
and i'm not listing all of them
so all this work almost all this work
look at optimization and statistical
side separately so they cannot actually
show
that simple heuristics actually learn
the algorithm
and one exception is busy at all 2017
then they can
show that with linear and the quadratic
discriminators
we can learn gaussian distribution but
um
gaussian distribution might not be good
enough
for us to understand again
and in this setting we take a further
step
by starting one layer generator so
we studied the generator of this form so
ga is primarized by a matrix a of
dimension
d times k so it maps from the input of
gaussian distribution of dimension k to
output image of dimension
d and the form of the generator is just
a linear map
composite with a non-linearity so the
nomination can be
arbitrary like 10h sigmoid value like
value etc
and we study the proper learning setting
meaning that for the real distribution
there exists a corresponding a star such
that it matches the target distribution
and our problem formulation simply
becomes this
so we as we said we privatize the
generator by matrix a
and we will parametrize the
discriminator
by a vector or a matrix b
and we naturally are doing the ming
masking
like this but now
one important question to ask is what
kind of discriminated class
should we choose to learn the real
distribution
from the design of w again we see that
we should
choose the determinator of all
the plus one function but of course that
will be
two computational uh intractable
and uh actually is not needed
actually the choice of the discriminator
class
should attain a self-balance between
those different properties first it
should have
enough identifiability power so meaning
that
it should be large enough so that ga
which is the maximum over other
discriminator functions
will have an optimal solution that
matches your target distribution
if it's too simple you can not identify
the target distribution from this kind
of uh
function and in our setting
uh what is our target we are actually
trying to
learn a star-star transpose instead of
specifically matching a star because
the input is from gaussian distribution
and has some symmetric property so if we
rotate
the input by a matrix u the target
diffusion doesn't change
so we might not be able to exactly learn
a specific
specific a star but as long as we learn
some a such that a a transpose equals to
a star is the transpose that's fine
and the second the discriminator class
um
we can see that to have enough
identifiability power
all which is fine function naturally is
enough but that's not what we want
uh it should also be small enough so
that we can learn
with fewer examples so we want to attain
generalizability and third
we also want to attain uh stability
meaning that simple heuristics
local algorithms like gradient descent
ascent will
converge and hopefully will converge to
global optimal point
so now let's see how we can design
the discriminator and how we can
possibly
learn the distribution so first
we will study the population risk
meaning
we have infinite number of samples and
this part just help us to understand the
optimization side
and later we'll move on to finite sample
case
so as a warm-up let's first look at how
to learn the marginal distribution
so recall our function is a
will be a nice game over this kind of
function
and to learn the marginal distribution
means we want to match the distribution
for each
coordinate of the x i and
from our design each x i actually
follows a distribution like this so it's
naturally a gaussian distribution of its
mean
zero and variance a i is norm squared a
i
is the i's row of matrix a
recall a is dimension d times k
and the x i will just follow b
uh composite with this gaussian
random variable and in this case we can
say to learn the marginal distribution
is to recover each norm of a i
squared and in other words it's the
diagonal part of a star
star transpose
and so for the three different
properties we can see
now that uh in order to identify the
margin diffusion
is exactly equal to the coverage norm of
ai
and the also in order to achieve
generalizability
we start to think from the simplest
discriminator class
uh which is linear discriminator class
let's see whether we can recover this ai
um so for linear discriminator the
function naturally becomes
dv x equals to v transpose x
and so our function becomes something
like this
it is trying to match v transpose x
with the v transpose v uh the
generated variable so
in this form we can see that linear
discriminator is trying to match the
first moment
for the distribution and
for some kinds of activation functions
this is actually
enough
yeah sorry i took a look at the chat
channel
um for something like vanduul or leaky
relu
so this is enough because
for different choices the choices of a
ice norm
uh the mean of x and the phi a c will be
different and uh to match the mean
of x will actually give us the norm of
ai
but for some other kinds of activations
like all functions plus constant
such as a sigmoid and and 10h
actually due to this symmetry of
gaussian
the expectation of x or vx will
remain the same for different choice of
a i swarm
so in this case we use rectified linear
discriminator to create some
non-symmetry
such that for different a i's norm
the mean will be different so that if we
mean if we match the
first moment they will still be the same
and uh certainly about stability
so uh there are some fireworks that
say that if the min max problem is
uh linear in the next part it will we
will not
year less iterate convergence and uh
luckily for uh for w against we actually
have some constraint
on the discriminator so remember
we should look at liquidus one function
so this is essentially some kind of
regular riser
on the discriminator class and we we
choose to use a simple version of it
which is
the minus sum l2 regular riser to it
and luckily with this form the maximum
naturally becomes the
the l2 distance between
the mean of the real distribution and
the mean of generated distribution
and this actually makes the mmx problem
very very nice to be solved
and to conclude on the marginal
distribution side
um for activations including
liquid relu subpassing more than 10h
all the station point of the f5
of f1 we talked about your yield
parameter a such that a
i's normal matches the target
distributions a is normal
and on the stability side of the
convergence side
we can also show that gradient descent
ascend can
converge to the global max point such
that
it matches this kind of properties
and then so next let's move forward
to look at the joint distribution
from the previous design of the
discriminator
class we can see that there is no
interactions between each
each coordinate of x so there was no
hope to learn the joint distribution
to proceed uh we want to add such
interactions between the quantities so
a natural idea is to look at quadratic
discriminators
and actually quadratic discriminator can
capture the covariance of the target
diffusion
so let's see the discriminator
looks like x transpose v x and we can
also write it
as the inner product between excess
transpose
and the parameter for the discriminator
function
v therefore
again with regularized version the max
part will can be written like this
so in order to minimize this function
it's actually
equivalent to matching the second moment
of the target and learn distributions
and to to proceed we need to study the
geometry of this function luckily
with the help with permit extension
we can write out this function as
something of this form so if we write
a function b the activation function as
uh the summation of some coefficient
times each
function then we can write ga as
the summation of each army coefficient
squared
times a a transpose to the hardware
um of power i minus a transpose
to target power i this is because
of the following property of argument
expansion
so for any functions that can be written
as the hermit expansion
of the if the input is gaussian
is unit gaussian then the expectation of
b
u transpose v times v of v transpose c
can be written as summation of the
parameter
squared times u transpose v to the ice
power
therefore with the same thing we can
write out ga
as the following form and from this form
we can see
that there are some very good properties
um because uh
we only aa transpose place a row
here so we can actually do the bowling
with privatization
that we write out z equals to a a
transpose and the
d star equals a star is star transpose
now we write g
a to be this following form
with with this form a very good property
is that each coordinate of z is
contributing separately to g
so we can write out the g 2 z
as the following form the summation
of g 2 dot j so each quantity
is j j's row case column of z
and that's the following form uh this is
good because
for such scatter functions it is much
easier to study its stationary point
and actually we can find out for
some classes of activations for example
odd functions plus constant and the
leaky value
this function satisfies that all station
points
are global mean meaning that our station
point
must have z matches this star
therefore on learning the joint
distribution we can show that for
activations including
nikki value 10hc void g20 has
a unique station point such that the
first a star star transpose
and in this case gradient descent ascent
also converges to
the optimal solution that matches a star
is the transpose
notice that if once we learn this a star
is there transpose
we have learned the target diffusion
so then let's move on to the finite
sample case so
we're interested to know this polynomial
number of
uh samples as we can still when the mod
then the joint distribution
so in reality we will use a
finite batch size we have we don't have
infinite computational power
so for each iteration t we will generate
z1 through z m the best size
is m number of samples from gaussian and
we also use symbol size n of the
x i from the real distribution and our
min-max optimization
essentially becomes gradient descent
gradient step
over this geotilde mn lmn to indicate
the finite batch size and sample size
so the difference from previous
function is just we replace the
expectation
by the finite sum case
yeah so we match this
and with this form we can
also show that with
sample size n versus m to be large
enough
uh to be probably d over epsilon squared
now for large enough t stochastic
gradient descent ascent also converges
to the global minimum point
and the learned atat
transpose will be close enough to a star
star transpose
so here we have the absolute value of
the distance
because we assume a star has a unique
norm
unit and actually this dependence
on one over epsilon squared is optimal
because
there is some fine work that shows a
lower bound of order of epsilon squared
on learning such
generating models
so the proof sketch is
a little bit complicated and looks like
this so
remember that our target is
to minimize over this ga
that matches a star is the transpose
with aa transpose
and it can also be re-primarized to gz
and our gradient step is actually on
gn which is the expectation
over the the samples from
the gaussian distribution and the finite
sample case
so the proof
of sketch roughly is
the following steps first uh
it's very easy to see that stochastic
gradient descent ascend and w
again will be essentially
sgd on this gn
and with some prior work
uh v at r and g at all
we can show that stochastic gradient
descent
will find epsilon second obstruction
point
of g n in polynomial time
and for large enough mn so the epsilon
stationary
second oscillation point of g n actually
will also be the other
epsilon station uh secondary station
point
for this population disk of a
and the second order station point of ga
actually will be the first order station
point
of g2.z the parametrized form
and the g2.z as we talked about
previously has some
property that it has a unique station
point
of a star is that transpose so all the
epsilon first oscillation point
satisfy d minus a star is that transpose
is also of order epsilon
error therefore for large m
and n so all together we have stochastic
gradient descent ascent on w again
with quadratic discriminator function we
will find
a such that it's not too far from the
target
a star is that transpose
and in conclusion our work
study both the statistical side and
optimization side
jointly so that we can show simple
heuristics like gradient descent ascent
find the target distribution on
statistical side
we say that discriminator match slow
order moments
which avoids curse of dimensionality
so this seems simple but we can it's
easier to
take a further step on because
for discriminator classes like neural
network it can actually
approximate arbitrary many higher level
polynomials
therefore it can naturally learn
larger class of generator functions as
there
is some folder full of work the entour
shows that however of course for higher
moments it's harder to get optimization
results and under statistical
the optimization side will show that
with simple discriminators like
linear quadratic functions stochastic
reading decent percent can help us
achieve global convergence and to
and also adding regular riser
like w again does will stabilize the
gain training and
um make sure the single heuristics work
and to go beyond simple gains we might
be
will be studying the training dynamics
instead of as what we did to learn the
geometry of the functions
especially if we want to tackle for
non-complex non-complete midnight
problems and
that's it thank you
okay thank you any questions for chi
feel free to unmute yourself if you're
on the panel or
raise your hand in the zoom chat
i i have a question for you so it
is there any hope that you know some of
these papers that you're referencing
actually learn one hidden layer so you
have you know a sum of values or a sum
of
leaky values i mean is there any hope
that you can extend this work to a model
where you have you know
a a a matrix a times
fee of wx
yeah so on this uh statistical side
it's uh definitely uh
hopefully it's already done as uh
as here like lee and do it they actually
showed
when hidden layer generator model so
it's actually the same thing of matching
higher order moments but for
optimization side
it might be a bit hard
is the issue that you for these higher
order moments you lose that nice little
hermit formula that you have
yeah yeah i see and so there's just
it's sort of a stumbling block there i
guess yeah so
so output is not separable so well
it's very hard i see
interesting for more complicated
generators we will
definitely need more complicated
discriminator
which makes the problem non-convex
non-concave
and generally we actually don't know how
to achieve global mcmas for
general non-complex non-country problems
right
they are all work uh as i mentioned in
the related work part uh to achieve
local maintenance
but that's not enough for us to learn
the target diffusion in general
gotcha
any other questions so i
see that uh renee asked does your theory
tell us about good
non-linear functions for learning
distributions
so uh yeah so it's a good point
so as uh as we see here
so uh linear and the quadratic
discriminators uh is very simple
but it gives us the sense that the
discriminator
can help us match the moments therefore
as i mentioned here for neural networks
that can approximate higher order
moments
have other polynomials we can actually
match higher
order moments therefore we can also
learn more complicated functions
so it's on the statistical side
okay well um thank you again chi for
great talk
and we'll resume in two minutes
uh so enjoy enjoy your two minute break